- Good morning Believe Nation.
Today's message is drive emotion.
Over to you, ASAP Rocky.
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Espresso keep me going
- Yeah I'm 26.
I look at life through a
different point of view
than your typical rappers.
For me life is all about
vibrations and chemistry.
It's all about positive
vibes and negative vibes.
I think energy is
stronger than intentions.
I wanted to manifest
those vibes into my music.
I wanted you people to
hear my music and feel
a certain way, a sensation,
even if you wanted
to turn that shit right
the... I'm fine with that.
I want you to feel something (laughs).
I don't want it to feel bland and for you
to just be like "oh yeah he did his..."
no. I want to drive emotion.
- Your advantage as an
entrepreneur is your emotion.
Your ability to make
people feel the passion
for what you're doing in your company
to transfer it from you to somebody else.
That's how you are going
to stand out because
most companies don't do that
and most companies are boring.
What a lot of entrepreneurs
do is they look up
to these giant corporations
that you're competing
against and feel like you
need to be more professional
so you have a standard
boring professional-looking
website but understand you're always going
to lose to the bigger
company if you're trying to
keep like them because they
have a name people recognize.
They have a track record of success.
They've won a ton of awards.
They have referrals and recommendations.
They've been around,
so why would I ever buy
from you instead of buying
from the big company
unless you have a lower price and that is
the worst business model to
be in as an entrepreneur.
You do not want to be in
the low price business.
It's going to be a race
to the bottom because
there's always going to
be somebody who's going to
undercut your price and
as long as that person
comes in you're out of of business.
Your customers will leave
you because they only
were with you because of the price.
So the way to stand out, the way to win
as the little guy going
against the big guy
is your story, your
ability to convey emotion.
Let me see your passion
for what you're doing
because if i see that you're passionate
about your work then I'm
going to get a better result.
I feel like this person really cares about
performing for me, giving
me a great experience
whereas some giant
corporation doesn't care.
I remember I had a caller
call into my radio show
and they were in the
landscaping business and they
were frustrated that
they were losing business
to university kids and
high school kids who were
charging minimum wage to
do landscaping services
and he was having a hard time standing out
because he was three
or four times the cost.
I said why did you start this business.
He said "this is really important to me.
When I grew up I was
always outside with my mom
and she was teaching me about
how to take care of a lawn,
of the outdoors," and
here's the line that got me.
"every time I go to a customer's house,
I treat it like it was my mom's."
now I feel something towards this person.
Now I have a reason to buy.
That needs to be everywhere.
When I visit that person's website,
I need to see that message.
I started this business as a
tribute to my mom and here's
what we did growing up
and every time I come to
your home I treat it like it's my mom's.
Do I get that same vibe if I'm going with
a college university student?
Do I get that same vibe if I'm hiring
some big company that has a huge crew?
This is why I'm going to pick you, because
of your story and your ability to convey
that emotion to me and I'm
willing to pay more for that.
I'll pay three times
what you'll pay a college
student to do it because I feel like
you're going to do a
better job and no matter
what you write on your website.
You can write we do the
best job in the industry.
Everybody's putting that on their website.
It means nothing but
that story is something
that only you can put out.
You better have a good story
if you're starting this
business and you don't
have a deep passion.
Forget about it, go do something else.
You have that deep passion
then let me feel it.
Share it with me. Tell me.
Put it in your content.
Have a video if you're
comfortable to do it
but worst case at least have a picture
and don't worry about it
being super professional
because you're going to lose.
When you can drive emotion and connect
to your customer that's
when you start to win.
So the question today, I want you to get
a little bit of practice.
I want you to tell me why this
business is important to you.
Why did you start this company?
Why are you so passionate
about what you want to do?
Why?
Practice right now, this is your chance
to practice conveying some emotion to me
and the rest of Believe Nation.
Leave it in the comments below
and we'll join in the discussion.
Finally I want to give a quick shout-out
to Himanshu Premi, Himanshu thank you
so for picking up a copy of my book,
Your One Word, and
sharing that YouTube video
about it as well.
I really appreciate the support and hope
you are enjoying the book.
Thank you guys so much for watching.
I believe in you and
I hope you continue to
believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is.
I'll see you again tomorrow morning
for another shot of Ent Spresso.
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Espresso keep me going
Hey Believe Nation, thank
you so much for watching.
If you want to learn
more about this subject,
get a little bit deeper
on it, I'm going to share
some extra bonus clips
that I hope you'll enjoy.
- When I was younger,
about 16, 17, 18, 19,
I was more creating worlds and characters.
I would read a lot just
because me liking to learn,
I would read about
certain people and try to
get in their head and see
how they would write a song.
Now I kind of just write about my life.
I have this song called
hair blows on the new album
that's just talking about I
like when this girl's hair blows
in the car, and I wrote
that because I was with
a female friend of
mine, we were in my car,
and she was hanging out the
sunroof and her hair was blowing
and felt like the man, and
I wrote a song about it.
I think a lot of artists
mess up because you don't
know much about them after
a certain point in time.
I realized none of my
music would sound the same
if I just wrote songs
actually about my life.
Every two years you should
not be in the same place.
- But it does take some courage though to
be so transparent about your own life.
- A lot of people aren't honest because
they're not comfortable with themselves
- [Interviewer] That's right.
- So that's why you have
a bunch of songs about
the same things on the
radio because one, it's
comforting to a simple
listener, and two, people
just aren't comfortable with themselves.
If I was like hey, I'm depressed.
You'd be like "wow,"
'cause a lot of people
won't be able to do that
or tell you what they like
and stand for it and why they like it.
That goes again with a lot
of people being close-minded.
- Here's the thing though
people see you on stage,
they see you on tour for
years, we know you do well.
It's documented, but I
try to get onlookers,
fans, listeners, to
understand that there's
no difference necessarily in people.
- We all have the same emotions.
- Same emotions, we all go
through the same issues.
And even though you see
Tech N9ne on this show
in the morning or you might see
him on some award show stage
behind closed doors, he's experienced
the same thing your neighbor
might be experiencing.
- And that's how we make fans.
It brings us down to
a level playing field,
'cause they look at us elevated on stage.
They automatically looking
up, so when you tell them
I'm having a bad day because
my people are turning on me
and I thought these people were real.
It brings us on a level playing field.
He feels just like me,
that's how we make fans.
I tapped into emotions
and a lot of my fans
know about my life because
I put it in my records.
My wife didn't like,
when This Ring came out,
she didn't like that back then
but This Ring is the
best song I ever wrote.
When I did the song I Love You she said
"don't write nothing else
about if it ain't positive"
and I said okay (laughs).
My little girl Rainbow said
that she didn't like me
to do the lewd stuff on
stage, how I would do
Seven Words and lay in between the ladies.
So I stopped that. I do what they say.
These are the ladies that I take care of.
Alyia, she's 22 now.
She's out there in Oakland
having a wonderful time,
doing broadcasts.
She don't have too many problems.
Rainbow, I can't really talk about what's
going on with my little one
because she don't want it
but she got sick and I just God, why me.
She's probably like "God, why me?"
my mama was sick all those
years and now my youngster.
Damn, but in the midst of all that we
still have time to give
ourselves to our fan
and our people that want to hear it 'cause
it's a blessing for people
to want to hear anything.
Especially these days being in the game
as long as I've been.
It's such a blessing that
they still want to listen.
I'm going to forever have
these stories to tell
because I'm writing my life
and that's what I chose
to do back in the day
when Quincy Jones told me
"write what you know and
people will forever feel you."
- Damn, Tech N9ne.